[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'altro giorno ho sul tram e ho
incontrato un'amica di mia madre che non
vedevo da un po di tempo e come sempre
accade in queste situazioni
a un certo punto è scattata la fatidica
domanda ma tu che lavoro fai
cosa fai di bello nella vita ecco questa
è la classica domanda che mi mette in
imbarazzo non tanto perché mi vergogno
del lavoro che faccio ma perché è sempre
molto complicato spiegare cosa come e
perché faccio il mio lavoro
quindi a questa domanda ho sempre due
possibili risposte pronte
la prima che per tagliare corto e dire
che lavoro in banca che se pur vero che
a volte nel mio lavoro collaboro con
delle banche diciamo che una pura bugia
la seconda che la verità e dire che sono
una designer
ecco a questa mia affermazione
solitamente tutti ma proprio tutti mi
dicono ma che bello ma disegni casa
oggetti
io devo spiegare che in realtà sono una
designer di servizi e che mi occupo di
innovazione e principalmente di
innovazione sociale e quindi a questa
fine a questa mia affermazione c'è solo
da sperare che presto la fermata in cui
devo scendere per non evitare di cadere
in situazioni imbarazzanti diciamo
perché stefano perché rivivete non
capita mai io non credo tram
no non perché non mi piace a prendere il
tram anzi tutt'altro è proprio per
evitare di entrare queste situazioni
così imbarazzanti e poi comunque quando
mi capita io di solito me la cavo
dicendo sono un architetto che un
mestiere ben identificabile no cioè
tutti sanno che cosa fa l'architetto
anche se anche per me non è che sia
proprio la verità tutt'altro anzi io non
è che mi possa identificare in quello
che gli architetti fa e poi silvia lo
sai io posso essere molto noioso e su
questo è d'accordo anche abbiamo
reggente della scuola perché potrei
improvvisare lì per lì una conferenza un
paio d'ore che tra una fermata e l'altra
quindi la capolinea capolinea più che
altro parla inizia a parlare da come
l'uomo primitivo era già biologicamente
designer perché tutte le volte che ha
affrontate cercato di cambiare il
contesto che lo circondava agito è
pensato da designer per poi arrivare a
disquisire su quello che è il senso del
design e giorni nostri
per lei stefano io credo che qui il
tempo ce l'abbiamo se passi la soluzione
quella agricola con la cognitiva arrivi
direttamente al post industriale forse
dovremmo farcela
forse comunque l'ha voluto ne devo fare
devo fare il noioso è diciamo che ai
giorni nostri quando si parla di design
a tutte le persone anche all'amica della
mamma diffida vengono in mente dei begli
oggetti oggetti desiderati da molte
persone e credo anzi spero di non
offendere nessuno dicendo che negli
ultimi vent'anni
il design molto spesso è stato usato
come leva di marketing come leva
strategica per far scegliere le persone
un oggetto piuttosto che un altro ma in
realtà noi crediamo che la qualità
principale del design non sia quella di
generare forme ma sia quella in realtà
di affrontare e cercare si spera di
risolvere di risolvere dei problemi pd
un design che se prima si interessava a
generare delle forme e quindi a portare
dei prodotti tangibili sul mercato oggi
invece incomincia a occuparsi di modelli
sistemi servizi che cercano di
affrontare quelli che sono i problemi
del giorno di oggi del giorno d'oggi
quindi qualcosa di intangibile dal
design tangibile degli oggetti al design
intangibile dei servizi questo modo di
pensare il design è stato teorizzato e
nominato in vari modi forse quello più
conosciuto silvia è quello usato dagli
avere cariche è il design thinking
ecco cosa dovrei spiegare l'amica di mia
madre design thinking è un processo
creativo e decisionale che mette insieme
gli strumenti critici creativi del
design con i metodi delle scienze umane
col fine ultimo di arrivare a soluzioni
innovative anche partendo da problemi
molto complessi quindi anche ai suoi di
problemi della vita di mia madre
essendo un po c'è un processo che
mette al centro la persona e il suo
contesto socio economico culturale porta
arrivare soluzioni che rispondano i
reali bisogni e desideri dell'individuo
anche se noi impatto preferiamo avere
una visione un pochino più aperta della
cosa è parlare di bisogni della comunità
e anche dell'ambiente
il design thinking è un processo che non
utilizza solamente le capacità razionali
ma anche quelle relazionali come
l'empatia e l'intuito non stefano no sui
topi stava immaginando to sul tram che
cerchi di spiegare il design thinking
all'amica di parmigianità omaggiano si
aggiungendo inoltre la complicazione
dell'ambito in cui noi applichiamo
questo questo approccio che è l'ambito
l'ambito dell'innovazione sociale
sì sì forse qui adesso è meglio dire chi
siamo e che cos'è per noi l'innovazione
sociale
allora noi ci chiamiamo opaco design
collaborativi e crediamo nel potenziale
del design e dell'educazione per
promuovere e incentivare l'innovazione
sociale lavorare nel campo
dell'innovazione sociale per noi vuol
dire progettare quei sistemi servizi
prodotti anche perché no e modelli che
risolvono quelli che sono i problemi del
giorno d'oggi in una maniera più
sostenibili da un punto di vista sociale
ambientale e anche economico di quelle
che sono le soluzioni che ci sono oggi
sul mercato quindi un'innovazione che si
basa proprio su processi che ricercano
la sostenibilità ambientale e sociale un
classico esempio
beh direi forse una cosa in più che
l'innovazione sociale si differenza da
quella classica tradizionale generata
dal mercato perché se quest'ultima cerca
l'obiettivo principale è avere il
massimo profitto l'innovazione sociale
invece mira ad avere la massima
innovazione sociale economica e
ambientale
un classico esempio sono i servizi di
mobilità condivisa e tutti vediamo
sempre di più nelle nostre città e delle
nostre aree suburbane sistemi e servizi
che cercano di rispondere radicalmente
in maniera diversa a quello che sono i
bisogni della mobilità dico radicalmente
in maniera diversa rispetto a quelli che
sono i servizi di trasporto tradizionale
perché in realtà pongono al centro la
persona e la persona è utente e
erogatore del servizio al tempo stesso
quindi in questo in questo modo di
vedere il design
il design è uno strumento di sostegno
allo sviluppo di politiche sociali
proprio per la sua capacità di mettere
al centro i bisogni di una società o di
una comunità di riferimento con la quale
si sta lavorando è di coinvolgere in un
processo creativo e partecipativo tutti
gli attori che devono partecipare alla
soluzione di questo problema e io credo
silvia che questo approccio creativo e
partecipativo sia proprio una
caratteristica di fatto esatto parliamo
un po di più di cos'è pacco come è nata
allora pacco è una design collaborative
la prima e forse ancora l'unica design
collaborativa al mondo abbiamo la
medaglia perché ci teniamo a dire che
siamo una design collaborativi perché
sia nel modo in cui siamo nati che nel
modo in cui operiamo
tutto è basato sulla collaborazione e la
condivisione di idee conoscenza una
struttura che si auto disegnata
attraverso una serie di incontri con le
persone che non interessante quello che
dicevamo insomma l'obiettivo la posta
pirla e veloci anche obiettivo con lui
era comunque quello di lavorare in nuovi
ambiti del design attraverso una
struttura nuova che rispondesse hai
bisogno di armi è nata quindi parco
design collaborati una struttura aperta
e orizzontale fondata sul rapporto fra
gli individui individui che noi
chiamiamo powers che sono appunto i
membri di paco persone che portano con
sé conoscenze ed esperienze in diversi
ambiti sia tra le discipline tecniche e
quelle umanistiche infatti impacco non
ci sono solo designer e architetti come
me stefano ma ci sono ingegneri ci sono
sociologi ci sono psicologi un po di
tutto insomma
ecco i rapporti si fondono sempre su una
collaborazione e sul contributo
personale ha un'idea comune a design
collaborative anche un nuovo modo di
progettare testare in primis sui membri
da cui vita stessa
le idee che poi andremo
mentre i nostri clienti insomma le
nostre soluzioni
la design collaborative essendo una
struttura aperta facilità quindi i
processi dal basso di co creazione
prendendo il meglio anche da metodi
differenti senza utilizzare quindi
soluzioni precostituite e approcci
dogmatici questo crediamo che sia
l'unico modo per capire veramente quali
sono i processi collaborativi e per
identificare innovazione veramente
sostenibile
ecco è un approccio che noi utilizziamo
in tutti i nostri progetti in diversi
contesti socio economici culturali e in
italia all'estero quindi con giovani
adulti e bambini adesso stefano vi
spiegherà due dei nostri progetti
sì allora il primo progetto che vi
vogliamo raccontare si chiama design
school for children ed è un contenitore
di iniziative che ha l'obiettivo di
sviluppare le capacità creative e
progettuali organizzative dei bambini e
dei ragazzi
noi lavoriamo con bambini e con i
ragazzi in italia e all'estero anche
addirittura in africa in questi anni
proprio facendo delle attività
didattiche attraverso laboratori e
workshop che riportiamo a usare la loro
creatività trasformando trasformandolo
in progettualità e molto importante
questo processo perché rende i bambini
consapevoli di quella che è la loro
capacità creativa di risolvere i
problemi
il secondo progetto invece che vi
vogliamo raccontare si chiama parti
project che non è un servizio di
organizzazioni feste ma in realtà è un
progetto finanziato dalla comunità
europea attraverso un bando horizon
twenty twenty questo progetto ha
l'obiettivo di aiutare un'etnia
particolare che si chiamano sun
conosciuti qui in italia meglio come i
boscimani sono ritmi e emarginata in
particolare i giovani adulti quindi i
giovani che in questo momento vivono in
aree emarginate del sudafrica e della
namibia su questo progetto lavoriamo su
due su due fronti da un lato lavoriamo
con i giovani adulti attraverso dei
processi di co design in cui cerchiamo
con loro di individuare quelli che sono
i loro desideri i loro bisogni e perché
no anche i loro sogni e cercare di
immaginarsi quello che è il percorso per
arrivare a realizzare quindi un percorso
di autostima e di consapevolezza per
riuscire poi ad avere queste queste
nuove competenze e riuscire approcciare
entrare nel mondo del lavoro
sull'altro lato invece lavoriamo con
leggi o che sono presenti sul campo e
con loro sempre attraverso un processo
creativo e partecipativo invece
cerchiamo di insegnargli quelli che sono
i processi princi principali del della
fase di facilitazione quindi di aiutarli
a creare il loro approccio al suo design
in maniera tale che poi potranno usare
queste competenze con le attività che
faranno loro direttamente sul campo e
dai stefano ora la registrazione di che
cosa
la registrazione di quello che faccia
così a così una volta che qualcuno mi
chiede che lavoro fai che dico vai a
vedere il video su ted per alexandre
fedex alessandria grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]